yo is bootleg cab hot 97 five Lupe
Fiasco is here Los Vegas yes sir now
Lupe the album lasers man coming soon it
was supposed to be your last album was
gonna be not coming soon enough for some
people who you talking about I was
coming songs called lasers you already
know that though if you own air and then
you're watching this you already know
the name out it's called all right now
producer wise who you got on the album
well thus far I got the Neptune
soundtrack and I'm gonna keep the rest
kind of secret and simply it's a real
foot on kind of rolling rock so what's
like tentative tentative release date
for this no idea of me still trying to
put it together hopefully uh hopefully
about it into the summer now I know
shining down like leaked a lot earlier
than then of course you wanted it to
this that's one of my favorite records
like ever thank you will it will it will
the end up on the album yes definite
makeup every mostly every record that
you heard is leaked will make the album
in some format or another what's shining
down with that yeah there it is man and
um of course you drop that enemy of the
state mixtape yeah so we're good had the
internet going crazy and they're going
crazy for a couple days at first for a
couple days for a couple it's still
going crazy for that you plan on doing
anything else like that you know I did
like you quench you quench the lupe fans
thirst with that did the fair I 115
series a few years ago come yeah okay my
goodness take some I'm think I'm done
there it is often to the next house okay
what about your boy a gemstone Gemini I
know is he's gone all afternoon no he's
he's off the label but um he's still
good i sees out there doing this thing
so much support says to gym stock right
now I know I know I'm you kind of said
you know that you kind of came up on
west coast gangsta rap um I mean how how
I guess the Guru's death you know what
I'm saying I mean I mean were you at all
like a gangster fan coming up I Morris
more so told the toys like Dom not like
the early stuff right you know I was
wearing masks pill I still think math
skills when I don't be sad papi table
right
you know but I got into him so it's like
like sounds like a butter clouds you
know different different little records
here and there slowly became like a
gangster fan and the last thing that
what's the name of the chest collide
something chess club I'll city chest all
city chess club how'd that come about
man um just calm down man hahaha um I'm
meeting for the hole for a little home
ok I'll see chess club came together at
the show you know mr. MCS blue vob to
name a few Asher Roth you know we all
came together decided just put out a
little fun thing whatever make a little
name for ourselves whatever Austin is
chess club first record beyond being
right so last question last question
we're ever gonna be the crs album no or
an all-city chess club album either
neither all right there it is thanks
Boober